wir kommen zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt ein schwieriges Thema
die hohen coronazahlen die haben bei
vielen die Furcht wachsen lassen das
Kliniken ihre Patienten aussortieren
selektieren müssen im Notfall wer
bekommt also hilfe wer wird
beispielsweise noch beatmet wenn nicht
für alle Patienten an Beatmungsgerät
vorhanden ist Menschen mit Behinderung
sahen sich hier im Nachteil
möglicherweise und zogen vor des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
Bundesverfassungsgericht sah durchaus
Handlungsbedarf und hat im letzten
Dezember die Politik verpflichtet
unverzüglich Vorkehrungen zum Schutz von
Menschen mit Behinderung im Falle einer
sogenannten Triage zu treffen also wenn
ihr Notfällen medizinisch ausgewählt
werden muss es gibt jetzt einen
Gesetzentwurf aus dem Hause von Karl
Lauterbach zu Änderungen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes um das jetzt
sicherzustellen
und Kollegen wir haben heute mit einem
wichtigen Gesetz zu tun wo es um die
Belange von Menschen mit Behinderungen
geht und daher möchte ich zunächst
einmal ganz herzlich auch den
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für
Belange von Menschen mit Behinderungen
ganz herzlich hier begrüßen es geht um
die Allokation die Zuteilung von knappen
intensivmedizinischen
Behandlungskapazitäten sogenannten
zuteilungsentscheidungen im Volksmund
auch Triage genannt und da lassen
nämlich wir erst mal vorweg sagen Gott
sei Dank ist es so gewesen dass wir im
Rahmen der Pandemie die triatschnee
praktizieren mussten ich möchte mich
daher vorab bei allen Ärztinnen und
Ärzten waren Pflegekräften bei allen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
insbesondere auf den
intensivmedizinischen Stationen ganz
herzlich bedanken dass wir das nie
notwendig haben das ist nur möglich
gewesen durch die herausragende Leistung
die dort gebracht worden ist und immer
noch gebracht wird die Pandemie ist ja
nicht vorbei ohne ihre Leistung ohne
ihre Heimat hätten wir möglicherweise
Trier schon praktizieren müssen daher
danke von dieser Stelle hier für dies
was sie uns getan sie haben es uns
erspart durch ihren Einsatz haben sie
uns erspart solche Entscheidungen
treffen zu müssen worum geht es hier
zunächst einmal es geben Wesentlichen um
das Infektionsschutzgesetz und um
übertragbare Krankheit ist kann man
sagen die Pandemie ist doch schon fast
vorbei naja zum einen sie ist noch nicht
vorbei und zum zweiten wir leben im
Zeitalter der Pandemien durch die also
globale Erwärmung durch den zunehmenden
Verkehr durch die
bevölkerungszuwächse müssen wir mit mehr
Pandemien und Infektionskrankheiten
rechnen daher müssen wir besser
vorbereitet sein auch solche
zuteilungsentscheidungen als wir das in
der Vergangenheit gewesen sind so dass
wir sicherstellen können dass solche
zuteilungsentscheidungen auch getroffen
werden unter der Berücksichtigung von
ethischen Aspekten und lassen Sie mich
daher voll und umfänglich in den
Vordergrund stellen worum es bei dem
Gesetz hier geht man kann sehr
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein ob
beispielsweise die
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit eines
Menschen bei der Zuteilung von Medizin
eine Rolle spielen soll oder nicht ob
man Medizin praktiziert in dem eben
solche Kosten Nutzen Überlegungen
gemacht werden oder nicht das kann man
ethisch sehr unterschiedlich diskutieren
da gibt es utilitarische Positionen da
gibt es Positionen im Sinne von Kant
aber eines ist immer unnötig eines ist
immer unnötig und zwar wenn Menschen mit
Behinderungen benachteiligt werden
niemand darf benachteiligt werden wenn
der medizinische Versorgung auf der
Intensivstation benötigt nur weil er
Mensch mit Behinderung ist das ist
unethisch und das wollen wir mit diesem
Gesetz sicherstellen dass dies nicht
mehr vorkommen kann
daher ist es so dass bei den
Entscheidungen wer jetzt versorgt wird
ja oder nein dass dabei nur medizinische
Aspekte eine Rolle spielen dürfen
nämlich wie ist im Moment der
Krankheitsverlauf aber Vorerkrankungen
oder Behinderung können keine Rolle
spielen das stellen wir hier klar somit
kann es nie so sein dass jemand der in
Anlage gekommen ist wo er sich jetzt
behandlungsbedürftig findet dann keine
Versorgung bekommt nur weil er behindert
ist das wird nicht vorkommen das kann
nicht passieren und wir werden darüber
hinaus auch folgendes sicherstellen
derjenige der jetzt schon versorgt wird
der kann sich auf die weitere Versorgung
verlassen das heißt wir werden keine
sogenannte
exporttriage zulassen wir wollen das
System so praktizieren derjenige wo die
Versorgung schon begonnen hat der muss
sich auch darauf verlassen können dass
diese Versorgung legeartig zu Ende
geführt wird sodass wir nicht in einer
Situation kommen wo wir
unerträglicherweise unerträglicherweise
Versorgung beenden um sie einem anderen
Menschen zukommen zu lassen diese Form
der exposteria schalte ich auch für
unedig da wird die hier nicht vorgesehen
sind ist ausgeschlossen durch das Gesetz
was wir heute vorlegen
lassen Sie mich schließen indem ich
darauf hinweise das Beste was man der
expost oder Ex antertriage
entgegensetzen kann ist eine gute
Vorbeugung und eine gute Vorbeugung
läuft darauf hinaus dass wir tatsächlich
die Kapazitäten verbessern müssen planen
müssen wir haben daher große Krankenhaus
wir sehr Gesetze vor uns die auch dafür
sorgen werden dass die Pflegekräfte
nicht in ständiger Überlastung arbeiten
müssen dass wir sicherstellen können
dass wir genug Kapazität am Platz haben
wir werden daher das Gesetz evaluieren
wir werden aber auch gleichzeitig mehr
unternehmen um die Krankenhäuser von
solchen Leistungen zu befreien die
eigentlich auch ambulant gemacht werden
könnten sodass wir für die eigentlichen
intensivmedizinischen Versorgungsfälle
auch die Kapazität haben und das nicht
mehr machen müssen zulassen der
Pflegekräfte und Ärzte daher bitte ich
ihn bitte ich Sie um die Zustimmung für
dieses wichtige Gesetz und danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit
der die Regelung sollen durch eine
Änderung in das Infektionsschutzgesetz
mit hineingenommen werden also bei der
Entscheidung wäre versorgt wird oder
nicht soll nur aktuelle und kurzfristige
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit eine Rolle
spielen eben nicht Behinderung
Gebrechlichkeit Alter ethnische Herkunft
oder Religionen mit Behinderung vor
Diskriminierung in triatliterationen hat
Kritik von allen Seiten auf sich gezogen
und deswegen kritisch Siri ich auch zum
Anfang wie dieses Gesetz überhaupt
zustande gekommen ist sie haben als
Ampel in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung den Menschen mit
Behinderung versprochen dass bei
Gesetzen die sie betreffen sie auch
intensiver beteiligt werden sollen und
die Anhörung hat gezeigt dass alle
unisono alle Behindertenverbände gesagt
haben sie seien nicht entsprechend
beteiligt worden und das finde ich sehr
kritisch gerade wenn es um Menschen mit
Behinderung geht die es betrifft meine
Damen und Herren
aber auch andere Gruppen wurden nicht
beteiligt auch die Ärzte beklagen die
fehlende Diskussion und manche
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel da
bin ich sicher hätten sich auch
gewünscht dass es eine breitere
Diskussion geben würde und die einen
weil sie vielleicht das Verbot der
ex-postriage anders sehen die anderen
bei ihnen der Diskriminierungsschutz
nicht ausreichend der scheint auch in
meiner Fraktion will ich zugeben gibt es
sicherlich unterschiedliche Meinungen
und deswegen hätte ich es mir gewünscht
dass heute der Fraktionszwang der Ampel
aufgehoben worden wäre so dass jeder
nach seinem Gewissen bei so einer hoch
ethischen Entscheidung hätte entscheiden
können liebe Damen und Herren und
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
stattdessen haben sie acht Monate
gebraucht einen Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
den Sie dann innerhalb von drei
Sitzungswochen durch das Parlament
gepeitscht haben noch am Dienstag nach
Dienstschluss haben wir als
ausschlussmitglieder kurz vor 18 Uhr
ihre Änderungsanträge erhalten über die
wir dann am Mittwochmorgen entscheiden
mussten ohne mit anderen da noch mal
Rücksprache zu nehmen allerdings freue
ich mich dass bei den
bei den Änderungsanträge unsere
Anregungen teilweise wenigstens
aufgenommen worden sind zum Beispiel
dass entschieden wird
dass er zu rechtmäßig und rechtswidrig
triagieren wenn im wenn eben noch die
verlegt werden können und jetzt das
Krankenhaus ist entscheiden muss das war
vorher stand vorher gar nicht in dem
Antrag drin und was wir auch gut finden
ist dass sie endlich eine Meldepflicht
über die durchgeführten Triage und
einführen allerdings und das muss ich an
dieser Stelle auch sagen beheben diese
wirklich guten Anträge wir haben den ja
zugestimmt leider nicht die zentralen
Fehler des Gesetzentwurfs es geht
weiterhin nur um triatssituationen die
aufgrund einer Infektion entstehen
triarch-situationen die wegen
Naturkatastrophen Krieg oder
terroranschlage entstehen bleiben
ungeregelt und hier besteht doch aus
meiner Sicht genauso die Gefahr einer
Diskriminierung und deswegen hätte man
das logischerweise auch mitreden müssen
meine Damen und Herren der nächste
Mangel ist dass der Entwurf zwar
Vorschriften wie
meldow-dokumentationspflicht mehr
augenprinzip Facharzt Erfordernis
enthält aber keine Sanktion das
infektionsgesetz enthält ansonsten sehr
viele Bußgeld und Gefängnisstrafen ich
nehme mal ein Beispiel nach § 73
Infektionsschutzgesetz wird ein Arzt der
den Verdacht einer Erkrankung in Masern
nicht richtig meldet mit einer Geldbuße
bis zu 25.000 Euro bestraft meine Damen
und Herren bei einer Frage wo es um
Leben oder Tod geht und das ist ja eben
diese Entscheidung soll es keinerlei
Sanktionen geben das verstehe ich nicht
und das Verstehen auch die Betroffenen
nicht und ein letztes
zur aus- und Weiterbildung des
medizinischen Personal vertrösten Sie
uns in begründungsteil auf später ich
frage mich tatsächlich warum der gerade
vorliegende Referentenentwurf bei der
aktuellen Überarbeitung der
Approbationsordnung die sogenannten
behinderungsspezifischen Besonderheiten
nicht wie vom Verfassungsgericht
gefordert aufgenommen hat meine Damen
und Herren unter diesen Voraussetzungen
unter der mangelnden Beteiligung der
Betroffenen können wir diesen Antrag
nicht zustimmen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören
für die Unionsfraktion die einen eigenen
Entschließungsantrag noch einbringt und
die Kritik darin noch mal formuliert
dass eben das Gesetz nur die triarch bei
Infektionskrankheiten Regeln und nicht
beispielsweise auch für Fälle von
Naturkatastrophen oder Terroranschlägen
es gab auch bei der grünen Fraktion
Vorbehalte gegen diesen Gesetzentwurf
hören wir mal Kirsten Kappert gonter
heute beschließen wir ein Gesetz von dem
wir alle hoffen dass es niemals zur
Anwendung kommt
ein Gesetz was im Übrigen nur für eine
ganz spezielle Situation im Rahmen von
Pandemien gilt
die Klage von Menschen mit Behinderung
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
bereits
viel Wichtiges in Gang gesetzt die
Debatte um ein diskriminierungsfreies
Gesundheitswesen ist nicht nur eröffnet
sie trägt bereits Früchte
worum geht es nun konkret heute wenn
zwei Personen zugleich in eine
Notaufnahme kommen und nur ein
intensivbett zur Verfügung Stunde wer
bekommt es wie wird entschieden das ist
ein ethisches Dilemma das
Bundesverfassungsgericht nun hat uns
beauftragt genau hier zu eingesetzt zu
erlassen und das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist schwierig
es gilt nun im Wesentlichen das
Kriterium der kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit ergänzt
durch zahlreiche prozedurale
Sicherheitsmechanismen damit eben nicht
zu Lasten von alten Menschen von
Menschen mit Behinderung entschieden
wird und dieses Kriterium hat im übrigen
auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja
bereits in seinem Urteil vorgeschlagen
infolge der Anhörung nun haben wir
einige sehr wichtige Änderungen
vorgenommen es wird nur klargestellt
dass eine Triage nur dann erfolgen darf
wenn andere Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft
und das Kleeblatt Prinzip angewendet
wurde
käme es zu einer zuteilungsentscheidung
muss diese dokumentiert und gemeldet
werden das sorgt für Transparenz und es
wird klargestellt dass bei dem
Ausschluss der ex-posttriage
selbstverständlich
therapienplanänderungen weiter möglich
bleiben
[Musik]
zudem und das halte ich für absolut
entscheidend haben wir beschlossen dass
dieses gesetzevaluiert wird es soll
überprüft werden ob das Gesetz und das
Kriterium der Beurteilung der
zuteilungsentscheidung auch über den
Fall der zuteilungsentscheidung hinaus
erstens wo möglich mittelbar zu
Diskriminierung führt und zweitens im
medizinischen Alltag sinnvoll und
praktikabel ist und wenn das Ergebnis
dann vorliegen wird muss entschieden
werden inwieweit das Gesetz überarbeitet
werden muss
ist es nur mit diesem heutigen Beschluss
getan nein wir wollen grundsätzlich zu
einem inklusiven barrierefreien
Gesundheitswesen kommen und darum wird
dafür ein Aktionsplan entwickelt werden
darin soll im übrigen auch die vortriage
besonders in Pflegeheim ehrlich
thematisiert werden Quintessenz wir im
besten Fall beschließen wir heute ein
Gesetz was niemals angewendet werden
muss und geben den Startschuss für ein
gemeinsamen Weg zu einem
Gesundheitssystem in dem alle Menschen
die Hilfe finden die Sie benötigen
vielen Dank
war das für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen es kommt für die afd-fraktion der
Abgeordnete Martin sichert
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ihr Gesetz kostet Menschenleben dass sie
weiter an diesem Gesetz festhalten
obwohl nicht nur wir sondern auch
zahlreiche renommierte Institutionen wie
die Bundesärztekammer oder das
Max-Planck-Institut seit Wochen warnen
sagt viel über Sie aus es geht ihnen
nicht um Menschenleben
es geht ihnen nicht um Menschenleben
sondern nur um die Durchsetzung von
bürokratischer Kontrolle mit dem Verbot
der Ex post- blockieren sie den gesunden
Fachverstand der Ärzte und ersetzen ihn
durch eine bürokratische
lebensfeindliche Regelung angenommen
alle Intensivbetten sind belegt und in
einem Bett liegt ein hundertjähriger
Mann ohne großen Lebenswillen bei dem
man absehen kann dass er
höchstwahrscheinlich sterben wird nun
kommt eine 25-jährige alleinerziehende
Mutter die einen 99%ige Überlebenschance
hat wenn sie behandelt wird bisher hätte
der Arzt dann mit dem 100-jährigen oder
dessen Angehörigen gesprochen um zu
erreichen dass dieser auf die
Palliativstation verlegt wird und das
intensivbett frei wird nach ihrer
Regelung läuft der Arzt nun Gefahr dafür
strafrechtlich belangt zu werden ihre
Regelung tötet die junge
alleinerziehende Mutter ihre Politik
kostet Menschenleben und macht Kinder zu
weisen das ist völliger
das ist völliger Wahnsinn aber der
Wahnsinn ist bei ihnen Programm dieses
Gesetz ist Ausdruck tiefen Misstrauens
gegenüber den Ärzten sie wollen mit
bürokratischen
sie wollen mit bürokratischen Regeln den
Ärzten die Möglichkeit nehmen zum Wohl
der Patienten zu entscheiden und dieses
Gesetz ist kein Einzelfall es ist
Ausdruck des allgemeinen Misstrauens der
Regierung gegenüber jedem Bürger
Entscheidungsfreiheit und gesunder
Menschenverstand sind für sie ein Horror
weil sie das nicht kontrollieren können
so wie jede zwischenmenschliche
Beziehung in die Brüche kriegt wenn
einer der Partner einen Kontrollwahn
entwickelt so machen sie mit ihrem
Kontrollwahn die Beziehung von Bürgern
und Staat zu einer toxischen Beziehung
mit der Verschärfung des § 130 verbieten
sie den Bürgern über Kriegsverbrechen zu
sprechen obwohl das der
Menschenrechtskonvention widerspricht
mit den corona-impflichten nötigen sie
die Menschen zur Teilnahme an einem
medizinischen Experiment obwohl auch das
der Menschenrechtskonvention
widerspricht sie träumen davon mit
Vermögensabgabe Lastenausgleich und
Bürgergeld den erfolgreichen Bürgern das
Geld wegzunehmen und alle Bürger vom
Staat abhängig zu machen diese
Bundesregierung ist der Inbegriff des
übergriffigen Staates
ihre Politik kostet die Menschen
Wohlstand Freiheit und sogar
Menschenleben wie der vorliegende
Gesetzentwurf aber das ist ihnen
vollkommen egal solange es ihrem Ziel
dient die Menschen kontrollieren und
überwachen zu können
nicht die erfolgreichen Bürger die sie
von der Regierung und den linken so gern
bekämpfen sind das Problem der
Gesellschaft das Problem sind die
Bürokraten die in ihrem kontroll-
jegliche Freiheit Vernunft und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit im Keim ersticken
weil sie Meinungsfreiheit hassen wollen
sie alles zensieren was nicht in der
Weltbild passt und hetzen dazu sogar
gegen Ausländer wie Elon Musk um es klar
zu sagen den sozialen Frieden in
Deutschland gefährden nicht die
Meinungsfreiheit oder Elon Musk den
sozialen Frieden in Deutschland
gefährden Olaf Scholz und die
Bundesregierung
ich bin Vertreter der AFD unser Weltbild
ist das eines Staates der den Bürgern
vertraut eines Staates der den Menschen
Eigenverantwortung Freiheit und
Wohlstand ermöglichen will und dass das
den Grünen nicht passt das ist schon
klar
[Applaus]
wir werden dieses Gesetz ablehnen weil
dieses Gesetz vom Geist eines
übergriffigen Staates geprägt ist und
deswegen können wir dem nicht zustimmen
und hoffen dass sie endlich auch mal
davon wegkommen ständig die Bürger bis
ins letzte kontrollieren zu wollen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Katrin Henning klar spricht jetzt zu uns
für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren jeder Mensch wie alle
haben Vorurteile negative und positive
wir stecken die Welt um uns herum in
Schubladen denken ins Stereotypen
bewusst gerade aber auch unbewusst wir
können uns davon nicht frei machen dass
solche Mechanismen unsere Gedanken
Entscheidungen und Handlungen
beeinflussen auch wenn wir die beste
Absicht haben vollkommen
diskriminierungsfrei zu agieren kann das
passieren in im höchsten Maße
problematisch ist eine unbewusste
Stereotypisierung selbstreden dann wenn
sie die Entscheidung über Leben und Tod
beeinflusst wenn bei einer Entscheidung
über die Zuteilung begrenzter
intensivmedizinischer Ressourcen
aufgrund falscher Annahmen falsche
Schlüsse gezogen werden diese Gefahr
bestünde so hat es das
Bundesverfassungsgericht festgestellt
derzeit bei einer pandemiebedingten
Triage
Nachteil von Menschen mit Behinderung
und Komorbiditäten
erfreulicherweise musste eine solche
triageentscheidung in der Vergangenheit
nicht getroffen werden und wir werden
als Politik natürlich alles daran setzen
dass das auch in Zukunft nicht der Fall
sein wird
dennoch hat uns das
Bundesverfassungsgericht absolut zu
Recht aufgefordert für künftige
pandemie-situationen vorzubauen unserer
Schutzpflicht gerecht zu werden und
diskriminierungsrisiken zu minimieren
gegen Unbewusstes Stereotypisierung
hilft wenn man es besser weiß deshalb
ist es jede Anstrengung wert gemeinsam
mit der Ärzteschaft darüber zu sprechen
wie aus fort und Weiterbildung mit Blick
auf Fachwissen insbesondere zu
behinderungsspezifischen Besonderheiten
zu optimieren sind
darüber hinaus werden wir unserer
Verantwortung als Gesetzgeber gerecht
indem wir im Infektionsschutzgesetz
konkrete verfahrensvorgaben für den
hoffentlich nie realen Fall der Fälle
machen im Infektionsschutzgesetz Herr
Kollege Hüppe übrigens deshalb weil wir
uns als seriöser Gesetzgeber in einem
föderalen Rechtsstaat selbstverständlich
im Rahmen unserer Gesetzgebungskompetenz
bewegen das bedeutet ja nicht dass
unsere Entscheidung nicht auch in andere
Bereiche ausstrahlen können wenn es
tatsächlich dazu kommt dass eine
triageentscheidung gefällt werden muss
dann ist es richtig dass anhand der
aktuellen und kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit entschieden
wird dieses Kriterium hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht explizit als
grundgesetzkonformes Kriterium genannt
und nur dieses Kriterium löst den nur
vordergründigen Widerspruch auf
das einerseits ein Leben genauso viel
wert ist wie das andere dass wir leben
wieder bewerten können noch wollen dass
wir aber andererseits so viele Menschen
leben retten könnten möchten wie es eben
geht
richtig zur Absicherung für alle
Beteiligten ist dann auch dass wenn es
dazu kommt qualifizierte Ärzte in einem
Vier-Augen-Prinzip entscheiden müssen
und bei Begleiterkrankungen oder
Behinderung zudem noch ein fachlich
insoweit besonders wer setamediziner
hinzugezogen werden muss
wichtig war und ist mir aber auch dass
wir von Ärztinnen und Ärzten nichts
Unmögliches verlangen dass sie sich dann
wenn zwei rettungspflichten kollidieren
und sie rein tatsächlich aber nur eine
erfüllen können sicher sein können dass
sie sich auch künftig nicht strafbar
machen
rechtfertigende Pflichtenkollision nennt
sich das in der Rechtssprache die Lage
ist für Ärztinnen und Ärzte die in
solche Situationen geraten solche
Entscheidungen treffen müssen hart genug
da müssen wir liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union auch nicht noch
mit neuen kleinstteiligen
sanktionsregeln hinterhergehen und den
Ärzten zusätzlich drohen unser
Strafgesetzbuch das haben wir bereits
liebe liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
finde das heute hier vorliegende
Gesetzen gutes Gesetz es sind nun einmal
ethisch höchst schwierige
abwägungsfragen den wir uns zu stellen
hatten und die wir entschieden haben und
ich finde das haben wir sehr
verantwortlich getan und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
da kann ich Ihre Kritik überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen das haben wir angesichts
der Gewichtigkeit der Thematik auch
äußerst zügig getan es wäre absolut
unverantwortlich gewesen solche Fragen
mal eben hopplahopp mir nichts dir
nichts irgendwie abzuhaken bei einer
solch gewichtigen Fragestellung im
Kontext Leben und Tod ist wie ich finde
wirklich Demut angezeigt es ist deshalb
richtig dass wir noch einmal eine
umfassende Evaluation unserer Regelung
und ihre Auswirkung explizit vorgesehen
haben die auch dann stattfindet wenn das
Gesetz gar nicht zu Anwendung kommt denn
das ist
und bleibt unser vorderstes Ziel vielen
Dank
ja ein Gesetz von dem eigentlich alle
hoffen dass es nie zur Anwendung kommt
dass eine Trias praktiziert werden muss
die ja hier geregelt wird im Falle von
Infektionskrankheiten wie beispielsweise
eben kubit 19 Sören Pellmann jetzt für
die Linke
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen im heutigen weltweit ersten
triagegesetz geht es um nichts einfaches
als Leben und Tod um gesellschaftliche
Grundfeste und den Umgang mit den
vermeintlich schwächeren unserer
Gesellschaft vorab wir müssen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht und den
notwendigen Schutz des Lebens von
Menschen mit Behinderung sehr ernst
nehmen
aber Stadt fraktionsübergreifend und
ohne Zwänge wie zum Beispiel bei der
Sterbehilfe bei der Pränataldiagnostik
mit breiter gesellschaftlichen Diskurs
Lösungen zu finden Peitschen Sie dieses
Gesetz heute durch
Mängel wir fehlende spezifische
Weiterbildung externe und unabhängige
Kontrollinstanzen sowie unabhängige
öffentliche barrierefreie
Beratungsangebote Beschwerde stellen und
und und all das fehlt das zeigt eins die
umfassende Beteiligung vielfältiger
Akteure wäre deutlich wichtiger gewesen
ein Alarmsignal ist es aber wenn die
Beauftragten und Dussel schön dass Sie
heute hier sind für Menschen mit
Behinderung des Bundes zu wieder Länder
vor der Sitzung ein gemeinsames
Statement abgegeben haben und ich
zitiere aus diesen aus Sicht der
Behindertenbeauftragten von Bund und
Ländern hat die Anhörung deutlich
gemacht das ist schwerwiegende
diskriminierungsrisiken gibt
insbesondere die Einlassung des
Vertreters der bunte erzbundes
Ärztekammer nach der die Abwägung der
kurzfristigen
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit nach
medizinischen Kriterien fast unmöglich
sei führt zu erheblichen Bedenken Zitat
Ende
Menschen mit Behinderungen nennen
deswegen dieses Gesetz auch
selektionsgesetz da die aktuelle und
kurzfristige
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit ein
ungeeignetes Kriterium sei sie meinen
weiter mathematisch sollen mehr Leben
gerettet werden aber das Gesetz
opfert die von der Mitte als schwach
angesehenen zahlreiche Prominente
Menschen mit Behinderung sehen dieses
Prinzip daher als survival of the
fittest heute ist auf der Tribüne eine
der Klägerinnen damals aus Karlsruhe
Carola Nacke anwesend sie hat einen Sohn
mit dem Down-Syndrom auf meine Frage an
Sie wie Sie diesen Gesetzentwurf
einschätzt sagte sie sehr deutlich ich
zitiere sie die subjektive Beurteilung
da Überlebenschance führt zur
Aussortierung damit mehr Menschen
gerettet werden können werden die
schwächsten von der Mitte der
Gesellschaft geopfert
in unserer Verfassung ist jedes Leben
aber gleich viel wert dieses Gesetz ist
ein Zivilisationsbruch
Zitat Ende für die Linke gibt es viele
unterschiedliche Gründe heute dieses
Gesetz abzulehnen es ist auf
unterschiedlichsten und verschiedenen
Ebenen mangelhaft lassen Sie uns diesen
Entwurf heute ablehnen und mit dem
breiten Diskurs neu beginnen dabei muss
auch eine Lösung für das Problem
gefunden werden dass Menschen
insbesondere während der corona-pandemie
zur Hof passiert ist dass sie nämlich
gar nicht erst ins Krankenhaus gebracht
wurden frau Präsidentin ich komme zum
Schluss mit einem Zitat was Carola
nackig gern verwendet von Gustav
Heinemann man erkennt den Wert einer
Gesellschaft daran wie sie mit den
schwächsten ihrer Mitglieder verfährt es
geht für uns alle um das Wichtigste um
unser Leben vielen Dank
ja Sören Pillmann war das für die Linke
auch wenn die linke dem heute nicht
zustimmen wird das Gesetz mit dem die
Bundesregierung ja reagiert auf die
sogenannte triageentscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts das wird heute
hier mit der Mehrheit mutmaßlich der
Ampelkoalition abgestimmt und
beschlossen werden das war's für heute
hier aus dem Bundestag morgen sind wir
wieder für Sie da hier live im
Plenarsaal ab 8 Uhr 45 aber bleiben sie
jetzt heute auch weiter bei Phoenix